hey guys Pete here as of yesterday we
had 30 days until the new Twin Peaks
comes out and I was hoping for a brand
new trailer with scenes from this new
season but we got instead this cool
little trailer with what you need to
know so let's watch that and then I'll
come back and break it down if you've
never seen the show or the movie fire
walk with me then there are spoilers in
this so if you're watching Twin Peaks
for the first time right now then you're
going to want to come back and watch
this after you finish the series and the
movie Lucy put Harry on the horn
yes and Pete Martell up at the mouth
she's dead wrapped in plastic
Diane 11:30 a.m. at soiree 24
entering the town of twin penis Julie's
FBI right a just tail Cooper
let's see Lee left us a ring finger
under the nail guitar can let me in on
whatever the hell is going on here
sheriff we got a lot to talk about
take a look at this this is the diary of
or upon much of what I've been able to
decipher supports the contention of the
one-armed man and our repeated
references to Bob
what does Bob want bomb requires a human
host he feeds on
there is place called the Black Lodge
there you will eat your own yourself
last night I had the strangest dream I
was in a red room with an old man
sitting in a chair and I mean Dover
whispered secret in his ear
did you kill Laura Palmer you've been a
good vehicle and I've enjoyed the ride
but I promise I will
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's happening again Twin Peaks
season 3 is going to be debuting on
Showtime on May 21st and this is
exciting to me because I've been a fan
of both David Lynch and Twin Peaks since
I was a kid basically now I'm not going
to get into spoilers at all I'm just
going to go up what we have here and if
you've been paying attention to this you
know that they haven't really put any
official stuff out to give us a great
idea of what's going on this trailer
does though hint at some things and
while we won't be able to say for sure
where season 3 is going to go I think
this gives us something to start with so
what is this actually if there's nothing
new other than a couple seconds of new
footage of the forest at the end - what
can we learn from it here we have
basically a synopsis of the main plot
and we have footage from both the TV
series and fire walk with me which is
interesting what we don't have is a lot
of the characters and a lot of the
quirky stuff that some people really
liked when it comes to the Twin Peaks
universe in the clip we see Pete Martell
Colin Laura's dead body we get a look at
Lucy who works the desk and sheriff
Harry Truman at the Sheriff's Department
and we also get a shot of Laura's corpse
as they unwrap it from the plastic we
see more characters like doctor will
Hayward Andy the sheriff's deputy
Laura's father Leland Palmer James who a
scene Laura on the side and her best
friends on Hayward we see their
reactions to finding out about Laura's
deaths and then we meet agent Dale
Cooper from the FBI who's heading into
town to assist the twin peaks' Sheriff's
Department in investigating the Laura
Palmer case he's talking into his tape
recorder and tells Diane that it is
11:30 a.m. February 24th and that he is
entering the town of Twin Peaks
according to the timeline this is the
same day that Laura's body washed up on
the shore in 1989 we see Cooper meet dr.
Jacoby who was Laura's psychiatrist and
David Lynch himself who plays FBI
regional bureau chief Gordon Cole then
we see agent Cooper remove a small piece
of paper with the letter R typed on it
from beneath Laura's fingernail we get a
shot of Laura from fire walk with me
when she was still alive and then we
meet Mike aka the one-armed
and aka Philip Michael Gerard and Bob
Mike explains to us that Bob needs a
human host and we see that his current
host is Leland Palmer as he looks in the
mirror
deputy Hawk explains that there is a
place called the black lodge and then he
tells Cooper that he will meet his own
shadow self there Laura tells us that
she had a strangest dream she was in a
Red Room with an old man sitting in a
chair she leaned over and whispered the
secret in his ear that her father killed
her
the old man is obviously Cooper who had
this dream way back in the beginning of
season one seemed he are going back and
forth from both seasons of the show
actually and fire walk with me after
Laura talks about her dream that we saw
in season one we see Cooper and terror
gaining Bob / Leyland asking if he
killed Laura from season to Bob talking
through Leland says that he is that he
was a good vehicle and that he enjoyed
the ride indicating that he is leaving
but first he promises that he will kill
again we get a sequence where we see
Burnett Pulaski who was with Laura at
the time she died and then we get a cut
of the character known as the jumping
man from fire walk with me also we see
Leland killing Jacques Renault and then
part of Leland's death scene when bob
finally leaves his body then we get the
big cliffhanger from the end of season 2
that we've all been waiting for the last
27 years to find out what happened - we
see agent Cooper after he returns from
the waiting room of the Black Lodge
whichever interpretation you think is
correct and that he is now inhabited by
Bob himself we see a shot of him
smashing his head against the mirror and
we see Bob in his reflection after that
we get a couple shots of different
characters that we hadn't seen
previously in the in the trailer we see
Audrey Bobby Briggs Sarah Palmer another
shot of Leland and that is pretty much
the end except for a short like I said a
short new sequence it looks like at
least at the end of the woods what
stands out to me about this is it's
definitely heavy on the Lynch side of
things the map to the lodge the jumping
man popping up all this stuff is more on
the
David Lynch side in which it makes sense
because he's going to be directing all
18 episodes and has said that it's like
one big 18 part feature-length film
however Mark Frost who was the you know
one of the co-creators in the original
series with David Lynch has writing
credits for the entire series as well so
it's not going to just be David Lynch's
vision but this does actually look like
they're going to be picking up with the
themes that were popular throughout fire
walk with me and the cutscenes that you
got a couple years ago that sort of
filled in more of the blanks this is all
perfectly exciting to me but I wouldn't
be surprised if we don't find another
trailer that focuses more on the
characters since we know that that most
of them are coming back now I'm going to
do a separate video about who's coming
back and who's not because it's just too
much to put into one video here so let
me know what you guys think about this
other than being disappointed that we
still haven't got any actual scenes from
the show yet what do you think about
this I mean are you happy with the way
that this is sort of pointing the story
it's not that surprising obviously
Cooper good Cooper is still inside the
lodge or the waiting room and Bob is in
the other Cooper who came back to Twin
Peaks so there has to be something that
we learn about that but at the same time
were you hoping for more violence or do
you want to see more answers be revealed
about the lodges and that aspect of the
story that's what I'm hoping for
personally but I still hear people say
that ridiculous statements in my opinion
of like you know firewalk money wasn't
good or season 2 is terrible
I mean season 2 had it's bad points but
I still think that the last episode of
season 2 is the best episode of Twin
Peaks that there is so what do you think
let me know in the comments please
subscribe to my channel and check back
soon I will be doing more Twin Peaks
videos in the lead up to the season 3
premiere let me know what kind of videos
you'd like to see and what was your
favorite moment they brought back in
this clip for me it was the jumping man
I know a lot of people were excited
about that but that was an intriguing
character from the movie that we hadn't
seen before but definitely be cool to
see some more things like
there are a ton of returning characters
missing though we didn't see like
Shelley or of course none of the new
characters plus there's just a bunch
that we didn't see it all in this
particular clip so thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon